we're bringing you new updates from
Idaho in the case of Doomsday cult Mom
Lori valo daybell as her trial
approaches her defense team is making a
last-ditch effort to take the death
penalty off the table
the defense set in their motion earlier
this month quote even if the
government's new opinion of Lori has
some Believers that she is just evil we
don't kill witches anymore in America
the Doomsday had called Mom and is
facing murder charges for the deaths of
her two children J.J valo and Tyler Ryan
she is also charged alongside her
husband Chad dabell with conspiring to
kill his first wife Tammy daybell aside
from Lori's defense team calling the
death penalty unethical due to mental
illness they also point to Media
saturation of the case and Discovery
violations from the prosecution as being
big problems another big issue the
defense mentions is the lack of
chemicals used to carry out the death
penalty as an alternative death by fire
Squad is currently being debated in
Idaho lawmakers but the defense says
that two would lack moral decency
arguments on this motion are slated for
next Wednesday
we are about two weeks out from jury
selection in this case and Lori has
spent over 1200 days in jail because of
the pandemic and competency issues
between Lori and Chad Dabo who's been
tried separately for similar charges
taxpayers across Idaho have coughed up
more than 3.6 million dollars to cover
law enforcement prosecutors and other
personal costs here's the breakdown the
city of Rexburg has spent more than one
million dollars that cost comes from the
investigation into J.J valo and Tyler
Ryan's disappearance Madison County
where Rexburg is located has spent
nearly half a million dollars in today
and Fremont County has spent nearly 2
million dollars on the investigation
into Tammy dabell's death and with
Lori's trials slated to last eight to
ten weeks there's no telling what the
grand total will be
Terry if Lori valadebo avoids the death
penalty because of mental illness what
does that mean for Chad Dabo well he
faces the death penalty Idaho is still
one of 27 states that has the death
penalty and what the prosecution would
have to do there is to show that the
aggravating factors outweigh the
mitigating factors and if they can do
that and this is a heinous crime I think
they will be able to impose that and
some of those aggravating factors
include the fact that it's a heinous and
atrocious crime and that it's
premeditated and it's involving more
than one murder in this case it's
involving more than one murder and that
he is a continuing threat to society I
think they could show that as well and I
think that because this is one of his
beliefs and the fact that he has other
people who have been Associated like
Tammy dabell so I think that they could
easily prove at least one of those
aggravating factors and I think that
that would outweigh any sort of
mitigating factors in this case so he
could face the death penalty name a real
quick we don't kill witches anymore is
that a reasonable argument to remove the
death penalty or an overreach that might
cause valo her life
it's an overreach and the Supreme Court
has made it clear that mental illness is
not a categorical bar to execution
obviously contrasts that with
intellectual disability you can't
execute someone as a child or
intellectually disabled and you know to
Echo what Terry said what's worse than
killing your two kids one of whom is
special needs and bearing them in the
backyard if you believe in the death
penalty this is a death penalty case
Ryan
another day without closure in the XXX
tentacion murder trial the Florida jury
has now been delivering for nearly a
week but are they even close to a
verdict for the three men accused of
killing the up-and-coming rapper
xxxtentacion's real name was Jase Andre
in 2018 he was shot to death and robbed
while leaving a motorcycle dealership
prosecutors presented a lengthy case
pointing the finger at Michael
Boatwright as the triggerman Trayvon
Newsom as the second gunman and Diedrich
Williams as the ringleader and getaway
driver the star witness was another
co-defendant Robert Allen who pleaded
guilty to second-degree murder and
robbery charges he testified against his
alleged accomplices only one defense
team presented a case Michael
boatright's attorney questioned a
Broward County sergeant and detective on
the stand to poke holes in the
investigation the jury has gone over
Robert Allen's testimony surveillance
videos and thousands of text messages
and social media posts toward the end of
the day on Wednesday the jury asked the
court a question they wanted to see if
they're allowed to open the envelope
that contains fingerprint evidence the
court let them know they can only view
items they cannot break open any seals
all right I'm joined by my co-host
former trial Attorney Terry Austin and
our very special guest former prosecutor
and author of the book Harvard to
hashtag Nima Romani Terry today the
parties waived the right to return to
the courtroom when the jury requests a
break does that signal anything to you
well it signals that the judge is ready
willing and able to allow these
questions to go on the one good thing is
if you don't call all the parties back
for simple Logistics it will save time
and the one thing we want to do in this
trial is save some time because they've
been deliberating for a week now and
still they do not have a verdict he took
the time to ask not only the parties as
the attorneys he asked each of the
defendants they stood up he swore them
in and they all said yes we agree that
we should waive the right to be present
when the jury is just asking about
logistical questions now Nema I know
that Terry and probably all the viewers
want to know this but should the judge
just bring the jury in see how far they
are from a verdict and declare a
mistrial if they're too far
Brian no you don't want to even put that
word mistrial you don't want to put that
out there you don't want the jurors to
even consider the possibility that maybe
they may be deadlocked now obviously you
never know what a jury's going to do
especially a Florida jury but you're
talking about three different defendants
here and the jury may be pushing one or
two holdouts with respect to one
defendant or maybe two but if you're the
judge you want them back there you want
them deliberating you want the pressure
to be on and not bring them in and raise
the possibility that they might be
deadlocked after mistrial the whole
thing all right anyway let me take back
that m word I'm going to put it back in
my pocket and we'll see how this plays
out well we have an update now on the
lawsuit filed by the parents of Gabby
Patito against her fiance Brian Landry's
parents on Wednesday a Florida judge
pushed the trial back to May of 2024.
now initially the trial was going to
happen in August of this year part of
the delay is connected to a letter
Roberta laundry wrote to her son Brian
that reference bearing a body and and
how the words Burn After Reading on it
laundry's mother says she wrote the
letter before Brian and Gabby set out on
their fateful cross-country trip the
judge in the case will hear a motion in
May concerning the letter and whether
the laundry family is required to
produce it the potato family is accusing
the laundries of negligence after Brian
killed Gabby during their road trip and
left her body in Wyoming he then
returned to his home in Florida and took
his own life leaving behind a note
admitting to the killing the potatoes
contend that his family knew he had
killed Gabby but did nothing and instead
offered up a statement hoping she would
be found safe
the special prosecutor appointed to
oversee New Mexico's case against Alec
Baldwin has stepped down Andrea Reeves
says she did not want any questions
about her role as both a prosecutor and
a New Mexico lawmaker to cause problems
for the case attorneys for Baldwin had
filed a motion arguing Reeves dual role
violated New Mexico's Constitution Alec
Baldwin and film armorer Hannah
Gutierrez read are facing involuntary
manslaughter charges for the onset
shooting death of Helena Hutchins in
2021. Baldwin was practicing with a prop
gun on the set of the movie Russ he says
he did not know the gun had live
ammunition in it